Hi, Richard, how is it going?
Are you on mute?
There we go. Headset was...
There you go.
Headset was slow connecting, that's all.
Gotcha. How is it going with you, Richard?
Good, thank you. Very good, thank you.
Perfect. Hey, Andy, thanks for joining.
Hello. Hi, Richard. Good morning.
Good morning.
Alright, are we waiting for anyone else? Andy, is Natalie joining or are we all set?
Yeah, yeah, I don't think so. We can, we can begin.
Okay, cool. I'll quickly share my screen. So let me know once you see it.
Still nothing?
No, sir.
Okay, wonderful. So yeah, thank you, Richard and Andy, for joining our monthly business review. We're going to be reviewing the March 30th to April 30 scorecard and performance for Mark. Moving on to the next slide.
We have the agenda items, that's all the same. For the check-in, this is for you, Richard. How are things at this moment? Could you give us any feedback related to Mark's performance?
I hear nothing, so it's all good.
Perfect. Anything new?
Nope.
Okay.
Moving on to the highlights I have prepared to. Number one, we maintained consistent service quality across all work streams with no critical incidents or escalations to report. As what you mentioned, there are no recent events, no escalations reported for Mark. That's good.
And all planned leaves was managed proactively well in advance, ensuring zero impact to service continuity. So we made sure that we inform you ahead of time if we have an upcoming leave for Mark or if there's any absences or tardiness. So luckily, we don't have any for April. That's 100% attendance compliance.
Here we have the performance analysis. These are the IT by design recommended KPIs. Do you have any questions for this, Richard?
Mhm.
Nope.
You're good? Okay. For the utilization trend analysis we have here for five weeks, I can see that he's doing very well with his utilization, so we can see that he's fully utilized. There was for the...
Week four and five, there was a bit of a dip. That's because he's been working on a project. If you're aware of it, Richard, he's been helping out with the wiki migration. So that's that, but I don't see any problem with his utilization. Do you have any questions on this project?
Mm.
Kour.
Nope, that's fine.
Okay, cool. Moving on to ticket closure trend and analysis, I can see here that over the five-week period, Mark delivered an average of 98.6%. That's very high. And if we're going to look at the ticket
closure rate. Most of the tickets that's being assigned to him has been closing it same day. So that's perfect. There was just a bit of a dip from week April 27th to 30. He mentioned that that was a slow day and May 1st was actually in holiday.
Mhm.
an ITBD holiday, so he's not around. So that's the reason why there was a dip on that week. Any questions for ticket closure, Trent? All right. Perfect. I know you're already aware of the team GPS, so if you have questions, let us know.
OK.
No, no, that's pretty straightforward. Yep.
Same goes with other services that we offer. If you're interested in any of this, you can let us know, okay?
Yeah, you bet.
For the way forward, we have an upcoming company holiday that's on May 25th. Do you require Mark to work on that day?
Let's see, let me look at my calendar.
Sure.
In Canada.
The holiday here is the 18th of May in both Canada and the United States. So we will not be working that day.
But the 25th is a normal work week for us.
Okay.
So if you are looking for him to not be available that day, then you need to reach out to, he needs to reach out to his manager on site, Kevin, and organize it there. That would be two Mondays in a row that he would be away.
Okay, I'll check with Mark, but then if we need him on the May 25th, we can have him work. And on May 18th, we can have him take the holiday off. What do you think?
That is a good idea because that is the statutory holiday both in Canada and the United States.
Yeah.
Okay, I'll let him know about this one. Plus, he asked me about the PTO or SL request. Kevin mentioned that he needs to CC or copy the accounting at this email address. So that's fine with you?
Yes.
That's correct, yeah.
Okay, good. For the last item that I have here, I'm actually looking forward if we can move our monthly business review time slot. Are you available same day, but we can change it to 2 P.m. instead?
2 P.m. EST. I just have a meeting conflict. Or you can propose a time slot.
Kip.
Two meeting, 2 P.m. Eastern time, you said? That's 112, that's 11 A.m. here, yeah, sure.
Yes.
Okay, cool. I'll send the invite, so that's good. How about you, Andy? Are you available to PM EST?
Yeah, I'll make it twerk.
Are you sure?
Yes. Richard's available, I'm available.
Okay, wonderful. Okay, that's perfect. That's the end of my slide here. Do you have any feedback for us, Andy or Richard? Anything we can discuss?
Nothing at this time, thanks.
Yeah, just have one question. I know that you said there's no update whatsoever, but related to Zyme Works, have you heard anything when it comes to, you know, your decision? No? Okay, gotcha.
No, it's still pending is what we're told.
Oh, okay. I gotcha. All good. That's it. Thank you very much, Richard. Bye.
Okay. All right. Take care. Bye-bye.
Okay, thank you. Have a good day. Bye-bye.
Bye-bye.